uber and lyft drivers are on strike in
cities around the world the protest
comes ahead of uber 'he's expected
initial public offering that could value
the company at more than 90 billion
dollars jamie yuccas is in Minneapolis
Jamie good morning good morning the wait
time to get an uber here in Minneapolis
is about 12 minutes but those wait times
could be higher in other striking cities
around the country now that is rush hour
on the East Coast
drivers contend that with the company
about to go public the executives will
make billions of dollars while those
behind the wheel are running on empty
this is how a typical day starts for
Jeff Perry he's been driving for uber
for more than three years but his first
riders of the day are not paying
he takes his two daughters to school
before making the two-hour trek from
Sacramento to San Francisco where he can
earn more money driving but can't afford
to live instead he'll spend the next
five nights at this hotel so this is the
office yeah this is my office
while Perry enjoys meeting new
passengers he says he drives long hours
for uber with little to show for it
I'm just asking for a livable wage you
know is it frustrating it's super
frustrating because I'm not treated with
the same respect and concern that I have
treated them with to them were
disposable garbage and you can feel it
as as a driver you know Perry says the
first year he worked for the company he
made 60 thousand dollars before taxes
and expenses last year he says he made
thirty five thousand working more hours
he blames lower fares and reduced
incentives uber points to a recent study
showing drivers nationwide earned an
average 18 dollars and 65 cents an hour
before expenses but experts who studied
the company say it can and does change
its rates it constantly experiments on
the working conditions of drivers except
this is not a free consumer experience
people depend on uber to earn their
living when your boss experiments on how
much you get paid without notifying you
that can really wrinkle if things don't
get better
there's no way I'll continue to do this
there's no way I could continue to do
this we asked Perry to keep a video
diary of his busy weekend just finished
for the night it's 3 o'clock in the
morning just got to the hotel a lot of
people would say if it's this bad why
not go get another job somewhere else I
understand that argument but at the same
time this is a job that I actually like
doing so it's worth putting in the
effort and trying to fight for better
conditions and make it better are you
gonna do the out shut off Harry plans to
take part in today's call for action
drivers for both uber and lyft which
went public in March are calling for
changes including better benefits more
transparency and higher wages for a lot
of drivers this is a good bad job
compared to their alternatives because
it comes with additional scheduling
flexibility that they might not have if
they're working retail but in other ways
there's a lot to be said for
improvements like
come to this type of work uber says
since 2015 drivers have earned nearly 80
billion dollars with an additional 1.2
billion since tips were introduced two
years ago but in its IPO filing the
company says as we aim to reduce driver
incentives to improve our financial
performance we expect driver
dissatisfaction will generally increase
maybe even if anything good comes out of
this IPO hopefully the public sees it
and says you know what exploitation of
the workforce is wrong and holds some
accountability in a statement
uber says drivers are at the heart of
our service we can't succeed without
them adding that they hope to have more
consistent pay stronger insurance
protection or even fully funded
four-year degrees Norah
Wow that is going to upset the
marketplace certainly people can't get
their rights Thank You Jaime